for all those keeping count this is
Prince Harry versus the papers round
three joining him to Coronation Street
stars and a comedian's ex-wife little in
common by the fact they all claim to
have been subjected to the most
obtrusive methods of personal
information gathering
in their opening argument lawyers for
Harry claiming that from his mother's
death onwards as a Schoolboy in the Army
through to his life as a young adult he
was targeted by some mirror group
journalists who didn't think twice about
breaking the law to get their story
he claims they hacked his voicemail
causing no end of paranoia and distress
to those closest to him including former
girlfriend Chelsea Davey driving their
breakup
Harry's Barrister David sherb on KC
saying Prince or not the blatantly
unlawful methods used to get information
about Harry's life away from his Royal
duties was quite frankly appalling
as this trial gets underway Harry and
the other claimants will in turn be
called to give evidence it'll be the
first time since the 19th century that
senior Royal has been called to the
witness box and before he's even spoken
a word a victory of sorts in court
documents released at the start of the
trial for the first time mgn admitted to
Having learned one of its journalists
paid a private investigator 75 pounds to
unawfully find out what the prince had
been doing at London's China White
nightclub on one night back in 2004
saying it apologized unreservedly and
accepting the prince was entitled to
compensation and that wasn't all
while the publisher denies voicemail
interception and any involvement in the
case of Coronation Street actor Michael
Lavelle who was in court it extended its
apology to actress Nikki Sanderson and
the ex-wife of comedian Paul Whitehouse
admitting to some knowledge of hiring
third parties saying where historical
wrongdoing has taken place we have made
admissions take full responsibility and
apologize unreservedly but we will
vigorously defend against allegations of
wrongdoing where our journalists acted
lawfully mgn insists it is now a very
different company but in this case the
claimants team allege that over the
course of 20 years at the mirror Sunday
Mirror and Sunday people unlawful
information gathering was happening on
an industrial scale authorized by senior
editors including Piers Morgan
Morgan has always denied any knowledge
of phone hacking but in court it was
claimed that on one occasion he was seen
standing in a group of reporters
laughing whilst playing out an illegally
obtained voicemail left by singer Paul
McCartney
Prince Harry's hatred of the British
tabloid press is well documented he
cited media intrusion as part of the
reason he and his wife moved to America
and in just a few weeks time in his own
words at this trial he'll tell his side
of that story Katie Spencer Sky News